양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum의 기술
교육 디렉터예요. 이번 강의는 이 시리즈의 여덟 번째 강의이고, 양자 알고리즘을 다루는
시리즈 두 번째 유닛의 마지막 강의예요. 우리는 계산의 쿼리 모델에 대해 이야기했는데, 여기에는 양자
알고리즘이 포함돼요. 이 모델에서 고전 알고리즘보다 증명 가능한 이점을 제공하는 알고리즘이죠. 그와 관련된 기본 개념들과
양자 알고리즘, 그리고 계산 비용을 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지에 대해서도 논의했어요. 이전 강의에서는 위상 추정과 Shor의
알고리즘에 대해 다뤘어요. 이번 강의에서는 Grover의 알고리즘을 논의할 거예요. 이 알고리즘은 양자가 고전보다
이차적 이점을 제공해요. 소위 비구조적 탐색 문제에서요. 강의에 들어가면
설명해 드릴게요. 이것들은 모두 양자 알고리즘에 관한 기본 주제예요. 다른 양자
알고리즘들도 있고, 서로 다른 양자 알고리즘과 양자 알고리즘 기법들을 연결하는 일반적인 패러다임들도 있어요.
관심 있으신 분들은 알려진 양자 알고리즘을 분류하고 많은 참고 문헌을 포함하는 양자 알고리즘 동물원을 확인해 보세요.
개발에 기여한 원본 연구 논문들도 포함돼 있어요. 하지만 이 시리즈에서는
기본기에만 집중할 거예요. 다음 강의부터는 새로운 주제로 넘어갈 거예요. 하지만
먼저 Grover의 알고리즘에 대해 이야기해 봐요. 강의 개요는 이렇습니다. 먼저
다룰 계산 문제에 대한 짧은 논의로 시작할 거예요. 그게 바로 비구조적 탐색이에요. 직관적으로 말하면,
비구조적 탐색 문제는 정렬되지 않았고 유용한 방식으로 정리되지 않은 항목들의 모음을 검색하는 것으로
생각할 수 있어요. 그다음에는 Grover의 알고리즘을 다룰 건데, 이건 고전 알고리즘보다 이차적 이점을 제공하는 양자 알고리즘이에요.
그게 정확히 무슨 의미인지는 곧 설명할게요. 이 알고리즘이 어떻게 작동하는지 매우 높은 수준에서 설명하면,
먼저 초기화 단계가 있고, 그다음에 제가 Grover
연산이라고 부를 작업이 일정 횟수 반복돼요. 마지막으로 측정이 이루어지면서 탐색 문제의 후보
해가 드러나요. Grover 연산이 무엇인지, 그리고 그것이 어떻게
양자 컴퓨터에서 구현될 수 있는지 설명할 거예요. 그다음 이 연산이 무엇을 하는지, 왜 탐색에 유용한지
더 잘 이해하기 위한 분석을 할 거예요. 강의 세 번째 부분은 반복 횟수에 관한 거예요.
Grover의 알고리즘에서, 다시 말해 Grover 연산을 몇 번 적용해야 하는지에 관한 거죠. 알고리즘이
찾고자 하는 것을 찾는 데 성공할 가능성을 최대화하면서 동시에 비용을 최소화하고 싶다는 전제하에요.
탐색 문제에 정확히 하나의 해가 있는 특수한 경우인 유일 탐색 문제부터 시작할 거예요.
그다음에는 여러 해가 있을 때 어떻게 되는지 고려해 볼게요. 마지막으로
Grover의 알고리즘과 그 일반화에 대한 몇 가지 간략한 언급으로 강의를 마무리할게요. 이제
강의 전반에 걸쳐 다룰 계산 문제부터 시작해 봐요. 먼저, 우리가 자주 하듯이,
Sigma는 이진 알파벳을 나타낸다고 할게요. 이 강의 전반에 걸쳐 이 표기법을 사용할 거니까 계속
상기시켜 드리지 않을게요. 길이 n의 이진 문자열을 이진 알파벳으로 매핑하는 함수 f가 있다고 해봐요.
우리의 가정은 이 함수를 쉽게 평가할 수 있다는 거예요.
예를 들어 이 함수를 위한 불리언 circuit이 있고 그 크기가 n에 대해 다항식이라고 해봐요. 이것이
반드시 어떤 의미에서든 간단한 함수라는 뜻은 아니에요. 또는 이 함수를 특별히 잘 이해한다는 의미도 아니에요. 예를 들어
F를 계산하기 위한 꽤 복잡하고 지저분한 불리언 circuit이 있을 수 있어요. 다양한 입력 문자열에서 평가는 가능하지만 반드시
우리 삶을 편하게 해주도록 설계된 멋진 형태는 아닌 거죠. 우리의 목표는
해를 찾는 거예요. 여기서 해란 F가 1로 평가되게 하는 길이 n의 이진 문자열이에요. 일반적으로 이건 매우 어려운
계산 문제예요. 적어도 매우 어렵다고 의심되죠. 특히 입력이 실제로
함수 f를 계산하기 위한 불리언 circuit의 설명이라면, 이건 소위 NP 완전 문제예요. 이 문제를
형식화하는 한 가지 방법은 쿼리 문제로 보는 거예요. 실제로 이 강의의 목적상 이 문제를
쿼리 모델의 맥락에서만 생각하는 게 합리적이에요. 하지만 이 문제가 실제로 어디서, 언제
발생할 수 있는지 생각해보면, f가 불리언
circuit으로 계산된다고 생각하는 게 더 자연스러워요. 강의 6에서 봤듯이, 불리언 circuit을 가져와서
쿼리 연산 또는 쿼리 gate를 구현하기 위한 양자 circuit으로 변환하는 구성을 통해 이 두 관점을 연결할 수 있어요. 어쨌든 개념적으로 말해서
이 문제의 입력은 함수 f이고, 우리는 해가 있으면 찾고 있어요.
만약 해가 없다면, 즉 F가 상수 0 함수로 판명된다면, 올바른 출력은
해가 없다고 보고하는 거예요. 이게 비구조적 탐색 문제예요.
F에 대해 해를 찾기 쉽게 만드는 특별한 게 없다는 의미에서요. 이미
정렬된 데이터나 탐색을 용이하게 하는 어떤 데이터 구조에 로드된 데이터를 검색하는 게 아니에요. 그리고
도움이 될 수 있는 함수 f에 대한 어떤 약속도 없어요. 한 가지 생각해보면,
전화번호부에서 특정 전화번호를 찾는 것 같아요. 이름을 찾는 것과 반대로요. 이름 찾기는 훨씬 쉬운데,
이름들이 알파벳 순으로 정렬되어 있다고 가정하면요. 실용적으로 말하면, 검색을 쉽게 하는 방식으로
정리하고 저장하는 데이터를 검색하는 것에 관한 게 사실 아니에요. 오히려 복잡한 방정식의
해를 찾거나, 예를 들어 자물쇠를 여는 비밀번호를 찾는 것에 더 가까워요.
참고로, 그 모델의 실용적 관련성에 대해 어떻게 생각하든 상관없이 쿼리 모델의 맥락에서 이 문제를 생각하는 게 합리적이에요.
물론 실제 생활에서는 오라클이나 블랙박스가 없어요. 하지만 달리 알게 될 때까지는
복잡하고 신비로운 불리언 circuit이 일종의 블랙
박스 같아요. 이제 이 비구조적 탐색 문제를 해결하기 위한 알고리즘에 대해 생각해 봐요.
단순함을 위해 쿼리 모델에서 이걸 할 거예요. 함수에 대한 블랙박스가 아닌 불리언 circuit이 있다면
여전히 쿼리 알고리즘을 실행할 수 있어요. 하지만 물론 쿼리를 기반으로 하지 않는 새로운 알고리즘이
이 문제에 대해 발견될 가능성을 배제할 수는 없어요. 하지만 그
가능성에 대해서는 걱정하지 않을 거예요. 먼저 약간의 표기법이 있어요. 함수 f의 총 입력 문자열 수는 2의
n인데, 여기서 n은 F의 입력 문자열의 길이예요. 이제부터 대문자 N을 이 숫자, 즉 2의
소문자 n 제곱이라고 할게요. 사람들이 이런 식으로 대문자를 사용해서 소문자
버전의 2의 거듭제곱을 나타내는 건 꽤 일반적이에요. 대문자 N에 대해 꽤 많이 이야기할 거니까 이렇게 하면
편리하고 좀 더 깔끔하게 정리되겠죠. 그리고 이 표기법은
강의 전반에 걸쳐 적용돼요. 이제 물론 우리가 선택하는 어떤 순서로든 가능한 모든 n비트 문자열을 간단히
반복하여 각각에 F를 평가함으로써 탐색 문제를 고전적으로 해결할 수 있어요.
어느 시점에서 해를 찾으면 멈출 수 있지만, 최악의 경우 모든 단일
입력 문자열에 F를 평가하게 돼요. 그래서 이건 N, 즉 대문자 N번의
쿼리가 필요해요. 이 계산의 비용을 다른 방식으로 측정할 수도 있어요. 쿼리 횟수만이 아니라, 하지만 쿼리 횟수는
함수 f를 평가해야 하는 횟수를 나타내고, f의 평가가 비용을 지배할 것이라고 예상하는 게 합리적이에요.
이건 실제로 결정론적 알고리즘으로 할 수 있는 최선이에요.
다시 말하지만, 이건 쿼리 모델의 맥락에서예요. 만약 우리가 모든 입력
문자열 중 하나를 제외한 나머지를 모두 쿼리했고, F가 지금까지 그것들 모두에서 값 0을 취했다면, 마지막
문자열이 해가 아니라고 어떻게 확신할 수 있을까요? 답은 확신할 수 없다는 거예요. 그러니까 최악의 경우 N번의 쿼리가 모두
필요해요. 무작위성을 사용할 수도 있는데, 그건 해가 존재할 때 찾는 데 필요한
예상 쿼리 횟수를 줄이는 것과 같은 약간의 소소한 개선을 제공할 수 있어요. 또는 실제로 쿼리 감소를 위해 정확도
확률을 거래할 수도 있어요. 하지만 어떻게 접근하든 여전히 선형적인 쿼리 횟수가 필요해요.
N에서요. 그러니까 고전적으로 말하면 선형적인 쿼리 횟수, 즉
대문자 N에 대해 선형적인 쿼리가 필요해요. Grover의 알고리즘은 더 잘하는 탐색을 위한 양자 알고리즘이에요. 단지
N의 제곱근의 big-O 쿼리만 필요해요. 그 쿼리들은 중첩 상태에서 일어나니까 마법은 아니지만
고전적으로 가능한 것보다는 상당한 개선이에요. 이게 바로 이차적
이점이 의미하는 거예요. 고전 대비 양자의 이 이차적 이점이 실용적인 이점으로 전환될 수 있을까요?
가까운 미래에는 아마 아니겠지만, 먼 미래에는 모를 일이에요. 하지만 설령
Grover의 알고리즘이 탐색에 실용적인 이점으로 이어지지 않더라도, 그럼에도 불구하고 양자 알고리즘의
기초의 중요한 부분이에요. 잘 이해할 가치가 있죠. Grover의 알고리즘 자체로 넘어가기 전에
소위 위상 쿼리 gate에 대해 간략히 이야기해야 해요. 쿼리 모델의 많은 양자 알고리즘들이 자연스럽게
위상 쿼리 gate를 사용하여 표현되고, Grover의 알고리즘이 특정한
예시임을 알게 될 거예요. 먼저 우리가 이야기해온 형태의 함수 f에 대한 일반적인 쿼리 gate를 빠르게 살펴봐요.
쿼리 gate UF는 화면에 표시된 것처럼 표준 기저 상태에 대해 정의돼요.
그리고 표준 기저 상태의 중첩에 대해서는 작용이 선형성에 의해 결정돼요. 상기해 볼 가치가 있는 건
f에 대한 불리언 circuit에서 이 연산 UF를 위한 circuit을 실제로 만들 수 있다는 거예요. 비용은
불리언 circuit의 크기에 대해 선형이에요. 반면에 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate는
ZF라는 이름으로 나타내고 이런 식으로 작동해요. 특히 이 gate는
소문자 n개의 qubit에서 작동해요. UF와 달리 소문자 n+1개의 qubit이 아니라요. 기본적으로 함수 값을
추가 qubit에 XOR하는 대신 자동으로 위상으로 킥하죠. UF에서는
그렇게 했었죠. 그러니까 UF gate에 위상 킥백을 사용하면 어떻게 되는지 생각해보면
기본적으로 ZF gate를 구현하는 거예요. 마이너스 상태가 필요하고 UF의
평가 한 번이 필요하지만, 실제로 마이너스 상태를 되돌려 받아서 원하면 다음에 사용할 수도 있고
그냥 버릴 수도 있어요. 그게 위상 쿼리 gate예요. 만약 우리에게
위상 쿼리 gate ZF만 주어지고, 이게 함수 f에 접근하는 유일한 방법이라면, 실제로
UF gate를 복구할 수 없어요. 하지만 ZF의 제어 버전이 있다면
UF gate를 만들 수 있어요. 그건 연습 문제로
남겨 둘게요. 함수 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate 외에도 n비트
or 함수에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate도 필요해요. 다시 말해 이 함수는 all-zero 문자열이 입력될 때 값이 0이고, 그 외에는
값이 1이에요. 명시적으로 zor이 표준 기저 상태에서 어떻게 작동하는지는
화면에 표시돼 있어요. 이 gate는 함수 f에 의존하지 않으므로
아무 쿼리도 필요 없어요. 그리고 이 연산을 구현하는 양자 circuit을 만드는 한 가지 방법은 뭔가를 하는 거예요.
함수 f에 했던 것과 비슷하게요. 다만 n비트에 대한 or 함수를 계산하는 불리언 circuit으로 시작하는 거예요.
이제 이 gate들이 생겼으니 다음 섹션으로 넘어갈 준비가 됐어요.
이제 Grover의 알고리즘에 대해 논의할 거예요. 알고리즘 설명부터 시작해요. 소문자 n개의
qubit을 각각 플러스 상태로 초기화하는 것으로 시작해요. 다시 말해 이 qubit들을 길이 n의 모든
이진 문자열의 동등한 중첩 상태로 만드는 거예요. 우리가 할 건 이 qubit들의 상태를
해를 향해 효과적으로 유도하는 거예요. 그러니까 이 상태에서 시작하는 게 직관적이에요. 아직 함수 f에 대해 아무것도 모르니까요.
이 시점에서 모든 문자열이 해일 가능성이 동등해요. 그리고 이 qubit들이 모든 문자열의 동등한 중첩 상태에 있다는 사실이 그걸 반영해요.
그다음 반복해요. Grover 연산을 반복적으로 적용하는데, 이게 바로 알고리즘의
핵심이에요. 잠깐 후에 설명할게요. 이 연산을 총 T번 적용해요. T는 음이 아닌 어떤 정수인데,
이 숫자는 알고리즘 자체로 명시되지 않아요. 어떻게든 T를 선택해야 하고, 다음
섹션에서 T의 좋은 선택에 대해 이야기할 거예요. 하지만 지금은 이 반복 횟수 T를
임의적이라고 생각할 수 있어요. 마지막으로 표준 기저에서 측정하면
후보 해를 얻어요. 그게 실제로 해라는 보장은 없지만, T를 잘 선택하면
해를 얻을 확률을 크게 만들 수 있어요. 그리고 여기 Grover 연산이 있어요.
G라고 이름 붙인 Grover 연산 자체인데요. N개의 qubit에 모두 적용되는 연산들의 조합이에요. 그러니까 이건 N
qubit 연산이에요. 먼저 ZF gate가 있어요. 다시 말해 입력
함수 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate이고, 그다음 Hadamard gate 레이어, 그리고 or 함수에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate인 zor이 있어요.
마지막으로 또 다른 Hadamard gate 레이어가 있어요. 그래서 2단계에서 한 번의 반복은
여기 화면에 표시된 형태의 circuit으로 구현할 수 있어요. 참고로 여기서는 4개의 qubit이 있는데,
일반적으로는 임의의 수의 qubit이 있을 수 있어요. 여기서 주목할 핵심 사항은 G를 구현하는 데 f에 대한 쿼리가 하나 필요하다는 거예요.
ZF를 구현하는 데 쿼리 하나가 필요하고, 다른 연산들은 F에 의존하지 않으므로 쿼리가 필요 없어요. 그래서 2단계에서 G를
적용하는 횟수를 나타내는 숫자 T가 필요한 쿼리 횟수도 나타내요.
여기 Grover의 알고리즘을 사용하는 일반적인 방법이 있는데, 물론 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 앞서 말했듯이
먼저 해야 할 건 T를 선택하는 거예요. 다음 섹션에서 그걸 다룰게요.
선택한 T에 대해 T번 반복으로 Grover의 알고리즘을 실행하면 후보 해
X를 얻어요. X가 정말 해라는 보장은 없지만, 추가로 쿼리 한 번으로 확인할 수 있어요. 해가 있으면
그 해를 출력하고 멈춰요. 그렇지 않으면 다시 시도할 수 있어요. 아마 다른 T 값으로요.
꼭 그럴 필요는 없지만요. 또는 포기하고 해가 없다고 보고할 수도 있어요. 앞서 말했듯이,
이게 알고리즘을 사용하는 유일한 방법은 아니지만, 탐색 문제에 적용하는 자연스러운 방법이에요. 다음으로 Grover
연산이 작용하는 N개의 qubit 상태에 실제로 무슨 일을 하는지 볼게요. n개의 qubit을
이름을 붙이자면 Q라고 부를 단일 레지스터로 생각해 봐요. Grover의 알고리즘에서 처음에 하는 건
Q를 모든 n비트 문자열의 균등 중첩 상태로 만드는 거예요. 그걸 Hadamard
gate를 all-zero 상태의 n개의 qubit에 적용해서 해요. 그다음 Grover 연산 G를 반복하고
측정해요. 모든 n비트 문자열의 집합을 두 집합으로 분할하는 게 도움이 될 거예요. A0과
A1이요. A0에는 F가 0으로 평가되게 하는 모든 문자열이 들어 있고, A1에는 F가
1로 평가되게 하는 모든 문자열이 들어 있어요. 달리 말하면 A1에는 탐색
문제의 모든 해가 들어 있고, A0에는 모든 비해가 들어 있어요. 특히
두 가지 양자 상태에 관심이 있어요. 하나는 모든 비해에 대한 균등 중첩인 ket A0이고,
다른 하나는 모든 해에 대한 균등 중첩인 ket A1이에요. 이 정의들은
이 집합들이 비어 있지 않을 때만 의미가 있다는 걸 지적해야 해요. 그렇지 않으면 0개를 합산하고 0으로 나누는 게 되니까요.
Grover의 알고리즘 분석을 진행하면서 그 가정을 할 거예요. f가 상수 0 함수이거나 상수 1 함수일 때
Grover의 알고리즘이 무엇을 하는지 특수한 경우로 처리해서 매우 쉽게 파악할 수 있어요. 하지만 그건
직접 해 보도록 남겨 둘게요. 당연히 모든 문자열이 해라면 측정할 때 실제로
해를 얻을 거고, 해가 없다면 하나도 얻지 못할 거예요. 그 경우에는 아무것도 없으니까요.
하지만 이 분석을 위해 이 두 집합이 모두 비어 있지 않다고 가정할 거예요. 그래야
이 두 상태의 정의가 의미 있으니까요. 참고로, 이건 꽤 일반적인
표기법이에요. 비어 있지 않은 유한 집합 s가 있을 때마다 ket s를 그
집합의 원소들에 대한 균등 중첩을 의미하는 것으로 쓸 수 있어요. 여기처럼요. 이 정의들을 이렇게 정리해 봐요. Grover의
알고리즘과 어떻게 연결되는지 볼 거예요. Grover의 알고리즘의 첫 번째 단계는 초기화 단계로, Q를 모든 n비트 문자열에 대한 균등
중첩 상태로 만들어요. 이 상태에 쉽게 알아볼 수 있는 이름을 붙이기 위해
ket u라고 부를게요. u는 균등(uniform)의 약자예요. 분석을 위해 먼저 주목해야 할 중요한 사항은
이 균등 상태 ket u가 ket a0과 ket
A1 두 벡터가 생성하는 부분공간에 포함된다는 거예요. 특히 화면에 표시된 이 두 상태의 선형 조합을 취하면 ket
u를 얻을 거예요. 이제 전체 분석의 핵심은 Q의 상태가
Grover 연산을 몇 번 적용하든 이 2차원 부분공간 안에 머문다는 사실이에요. 그러니까 모든 것이
2차원 부분공간에서 무슨 일이 일어나는지로 귀결돼요. 이제 Grover 연산이 무엇을 하는지, 특히
ket a0과 ket
A1이 생성하는 2차원 부분공간의 벡터들에게 무엇을 하는지 살펴봐요. g가 두 부분으로 나뉜다고 상상하면 도움이 돼요. 한 부분은 ZF
gate이고, 다른 부분은 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 zor gate예요.
이전에 나온 ZF의 정의가 있는데, 그 정의에서 비해와 해의 균등 중첩인 두 상태에 대한 작용이
ket A1 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙이는 것임을 알 수 있어요.
ket a0에는 아무 일도 일어나지 않고, 이 분석을 위해 ZF에 대해 알아야 할 건 그게 전부예요.
두 번째 부분인 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진
Z or gate에 대해서는, zor이 어떻게 정의되는지 떠올리는 것부터 시작해요. 쓰는 한 가지 방법은
화면에 표시된 것처럼이에요. 이건 이전과 같은 표현이고, 직접 표기법으로 표현하는 또 다른 방법은 이렇게예요.
우변의 연산이 표준 기저 상태에 어떻게 작용하는지 생각해보면 이 표현을 검증할 수 있어요.
특히 all-zero 상태에는 아무것도 하지 않고 다른 모든
표준 기저 상태는 마이너스 부호를 얻어요. Z or의 정의와 일치하죠.
그러니까 이 연산을 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼우면 비슷한 표현을 얻되,
all-zero 표준 기저 상태 대신 이제 균등 중첩 ket u가 있어요. H⊗n이
all-zero 표준 기저 상태를 ket u로 변환하고, H⊗n은 자신의 켤레 전치와 같으므로 비슷한 방식으로
bra에서 오른쪽으로부터 작용하기 때문이에요. 이제 지금까지 관찰한 사실들을 사용해서
G가 두 벡터 a0과 A1에 무엇을 하는지 파악할 거예요.
a0부터 시작해요. 먼저 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 Z or gate에 대해 얻은 표현을 대입해요.
그다음 ZF가 ket a0에 아무것도 하지 않는다는 사실을 사용할 수 있어요.
ket a0에요. 그래서 ZF 연산을 없앨 수 있어요. 이제 위에 있는
ket u의 설명과 ket a0과 ket A1이 직교 단위 벡터라는 사실을 사용해서
여기 bra와 ket의 곱을 계산할 수 있어요. 그러면 비해의 수를
n으로 나눈 제곱근을 얻어요. 이 사실을 이용해 결과를 평가하고, ket u의 표현을 대입해서
단순화하면 화면에 표시된 최종 결과를 얻어요. 특히 이
벡터는 앞서 제안한 것처럼 ket a0과 ket A1이 생성하는 2차원 부분공간에 포함돼요.
게다가 계수들은 항상 실수예요. 원하신다면
본인 속도에 맞게 검증해 보세요. 저는 이런 것들을 영상에서 빠르게 넘어가는 편인데,
원하시면 영상을 일시 정지하고 생각해 보시길 기대하면서요. 자, 나중을 위해 최종 결과를 정리해 봐요.
이제 나중에 사용할 최종 결과를 저장해요. 그리고 이제 벡터 ket
A1에 대해서도 비슷한 걸 할 거예요. 전과 같은 G의 표현을 사용할 수 있고, 이번에는 ZF gate가
마이너스 부호를 넣어요. 여기서는 괄호 안의 두 항을 교환한 것으로 반영돼요.
그다음 매우 비슷한 방식으로 진행하면 두 계수가
교환되고 그 중 하나 앞에 마이너스 부호가 붙는다는 점을 제외하면 비슷한 최종 결과를 얻어요. 이건 대수학이 풀리는 방식이에요.
역시 본인 속도에 맞게 확인해 보실 수 있어요. 다시 한번 두 벡터 ket a0과
ket A1의 실수 선형 조합을 얻어요. 이걸도 정리하고 다른 것과 합쳐서 놓을게요. 이제 G가
두 벡터가 생성하는 부분공간에 어떻게 작용하는지 볼 수 있어요. 한 가지 방법은 화면에 표시된
2×2 행렬 M으로 표현하는 거예요. 여기서 하는 건 첫 번째 행과 첫 번째
열을 ket a0에, 두 번째 행과 열을 ket A1에 연결하는 거예요. 이 시리즈에서 지금까지는
행렬을 주로 연산이 표준 기저 상태에서 작동하는 방식을 설명하는 데 사용했지만, 행렬을 사용해서
선형 맵의 표준 기저 상태가 아닌 다른 벡터 집합에 대한 작용을 설명하는 건 일반적이에요. 여기서는 G 연산이
벡터 ket a0과 ket A1에 무엇을 하는지 이야기하고 있어요. ket a0과 ket A1의 생성 공간에 있는 벡터들에게 G가 무엇을 하는지
더 자세히 알 수 있는데, 이 행렬 M을 더 자세히 살펴보면요. 특히 발견하게 될 건
M이 회전 행렬이라는 거예요. 즉 이 2차원 공간에서의 작용이 어떤 고정된 각도만큼의 회전으로 설명될 수 있어요.
이걸 볼 수 있는 방법이 몇 가지 있는데, 하나는
이 행렬 M이 좀 더 간단해 보이는 행렬의 제곱으로 표현될 수 있다는 걸 관찰하는 거예요. M만 보면 발견하기 어려울 수 있는데,
우리가 스스로 발견해야 할 필요는 없어요. 검증하기만 하면 되고, 단순히
오른쪽 행렬을 제곱함으로써 할 수 있어요. 제곱을 포함하지 않고 오른쪽 행렬을 쓰는 또 다른 방법은
화면에 표시돼 있어요. 이게 주어진 각도 Theta만큼의 회전을
행렬로 설명하는 일반적인 방법이에요. 우리가 회전하는 정확한 각도는 해의 수를
n으로 나눈 것의 제곱근의 역사인이에요. 참고로 처음 보시는 거니까
이 각도가 매우 중요하다는 걸 지적할게요. 이 분석을 계속하면서
계속 나타날 거예요. 역사인의 인수는 0과 1 사이의 수이고, 특히 여기서
역사인을 해석하는 방식은 사인을 취했을 때 인수를 주는 0과 π/2 사이의 각도예요.
그러니까 그게 M을 얻기 위해 제곱한 행렬을 생각하는 한 가지 방법이에요.
그리고 행렬을 제곱하는 건 두 번 적용하는 것과 같으니까, M이 theta가 아닌 2*theta만큼 회전으로 대안적으로 쓰여질 수 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
제곱함으로써 theta 각도만큼 두 번
회전하는 거니까요. 참고로 도움이 된다면 이 모든 걸 검증하는 다른 방법은 M의 이 최종 표현에서 시작해서
삼각법의 이중 각도 공식을 사용해서 M의 원래 표현을
얻는 거예요. 그리고 이게 ket a0과 ket A1이 생성하는 부분공간에 g가 하는 작용을 설명하는 M의 표현이에요.
앞으로 가장 유용할 거예요. 이제 Grover의 알고리즘 자체로 돌아가서, 초기화 단계 후
하지만 G를 적용하기 전에 n qubit 레지스터 Q의 상태는 ket u예요. 즉
모든 n비트 문자열에 대한 균등 중첩이에요. 여기 ket a0과 ket
A1로 표현한 ket u의 같은 표현이 있어요. 하지만 이제 이 각도 Theta를 확인했으니
ket u를 cosine(Theta) * ket a0 + sin(Theta) * ket
A1로 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요. ket A1의 계수는 명확하고, 다른 계수는 a0의 크기와
A1의 크기의 합이 n이라는 걸 관찰한 후 기본 삼각법으로 얻을 수 있어요. 그게 시작 상태이고,
G를 처음 적용하면 2*Theta 각도만큼 회전해서 총 각도가 3*
Theta가 돼요. G를 다시 적용하면 추가로 2Theta만큼 회전했으니 각도가 5Theta로 증가해요.
이런 식으로요. 그래서 G를 T번 적용하면 화면에 표시된 것처럼
상태를 나타낼 수 있어요. 상태의 각도는 (2T+1)*Theta예요. G를 각각 적용할 때마다 2*Theta이고,
시작 상태가 Theta였으니까 추가로 Theta가 더해지는 거예요.
Grover 연산의 작용을 기하학적으로도 생각해 볼 수 있어요. 이게 어떻게 작동하는지,
왜 레지스터 Q의 상태를 회전시키는지에 대한 빛을 비춰줘요. 주요 아이디어는 Grover
연산이 이미 확인한 두 부분의 조합이라는 거예요. 하나는 ZF이고, 다른 하나는 두 레이어의
Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 z or이에요. 이 두 부분은
반사이고, 두 반사를 합성하면 회전을 얻어요. 이게 어떻게 작동하는지
더 자세히 살펴봐요. 먼저 ZF에 집중해요. 그리고 우리가 이야기해온 같은
2차원 부분공간, 즉 ket a0과 ket
A1이 생성하는 부분공간으로 주의를 제한할게요. 이미 관찰했듯이, ZF가 이 공간에서 하는 작용은 꽤 간단해요.
ket a0에는 아무것도 하지 않고 ket A1 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙여요. 이건 반사이고, 특히
K a0에 평행한 선에 대한 반사인데요, 그 선을 L1이라고 부를게요. 반사인 이유를 이해하려면
그림을 그려보면 도움이 돼요. 여기 두 벡터 K a0와
K A1이 있는데, 이 둘은 직교하는 단위 벡터예요. 화면은 이 두 벡터의 모든 실수
선형 결합으로 이루어진다고 생각할 수 있어요. 그래서 원은 계수가 실수인 모든 단위 벡터를 나타내요.
여기 K a0에 평행한 선 L1이 있고, 원 위의 임의의 벡터 s를 생각해 보면
ZF를 적용했을 때의 효과는 화면에서 보이는 것처럼 이 선에 대해 반사하는 거예요.
k a z에는 아무것도 안 하고 K 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙이기 때문이에요.
s가 k a 0인 특수한 경우에는 이 반사를 수행해도 아무 일도 일어나지 않고, s가
K A1이면 반사를 하면 negative K A1로 완전히 이동하는데, 이건 ZF의 작용과 일치해요. 그러니까 ZF는
여기서 시각화한 것처럼 반사예요. G의 두 번째 부분은 z, 즉
두 층의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 것인데, 이미 본 것처럼 2 곱하기 K Bru 빼기 단위행렬로 표현할 수 있어요.
이것도 반사인데, 이번엔 K a0가 아니라 k u에 평행한 선 L2에 대한 반사예요.
이 연산은 ZF와 비슷한 방식으로 시각화할 수 있어요. 여기 벡터 k가 있고
가정적으로요. 이게 K에 평행한 선 L2이고, 역시 임의의 벡터 S에 대한 작용은 반사예요.
이 경우에는 선 L2에 대해 반사하는 거예요.
그리고 마지막으로, 앞서 언급했듯이 두 반사를 합성하면 항상 회전을 얻게 되는데, 구체적으로는
반사선 사이의 각도의 두 배만큼 회전해요. 비슷한 그림을 그려볼게요.
이전에 그린 것처럼요. 여기 반사선들이 있고, 그 사이의 각도가 Theta예요.
임의의 벡터 s를 첫 번째 선 L1에 대해 반사하고
두 번째 선 L2에 대해 반사하면, 전체 효과는 벡터 s를 두 배 Theta 각도만큼 회전시키는 거예요.
이건 일반적으로 성립하는 사실이에요. 직접 다른 예시들을 해보면 이게 실제로 맞다는 걸 확인할 수 있을 거예요.
아무튼 grover 연산이 벡터를 회전시키는 효과가 있다는 직관을 얻는 데 도움이 되길 바라요.
다음으로 Grover 알고리즘에서 반복 횟수 T를 선택하는 문제로 넘어갈게요.
지금까지 분석한 내용, 즉 grover 연산을 반복 적용할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지가
우리가 해결하려는 탐색 문제의 해를 찾는 작업과 어떻게 연관되는지 생각해 볼게요.
다시 말해, 집합 A1에 포함된 임의의 문자열을 찾는 거예요. 요약하면, 기본적으로
목표를 설정하고 grover 연산을 몇 번 적용해야 그 목표에 가까워지는지 알아낼 거예요.
먼저 두 벡터 K a0와 K의 선형 결합인 임의의 상태를 생각해 볼게요.
A1이 이 상태에서 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면, 집합 A1, 즉
탐색 문제의 해 집합에 속하는 결과를 얻을 확률은 K A1의 계수의 절댓값 제곱과 같아요.
화면에 나온 벡터에서 그 계수는 beta예요. 직관적으로, 상태 K a0를 측정하면
임의의 비해를 얻고, K A1을 측정하면 임의의 해를 얻어요. 그러니까 이 상태를
측정하면 Alpha 절댓값 제곱의 확률로 임의의 비해를, beta 절댓값 제곱의 확률로 임의의 해를 얻어요.
하지만 잠깐 직접 계산해 볼 수도 있어요. 표준 기저 상태에서 이 벡터의 원소들을 볼 수 있도록 상태를 적으면
측정했을 때 각 가능한 결과를 얻을 확률이 이렇게 돼요.
해를 얻을 확률을 구하려면 모든 가능한 해에 대한 확률을 더하면 되는데,
그러면 예상대로 beta 절댓값 제곱이 나와요.
이제 Grover 알고리즘을 T번 반복했을 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 이미 분석했어요. 화면에
나온 상태를 얻게 되는데, K A1의 계수가
2T + 1 곱하기 Theta의 사인이에요. 여기서 다시 한번 이 매우 중요한 각도 Theta가 등장해요.
해를 볼 확률은 (2T + 1) 곱하기 Theta의 sin 제곱이에요.
그 확률을 가능한 한 1에 가깝게 크게 만들고 싶어요. 그래서 G를 반복해서 상태 벡터를 회전시키면서
K A1을 목표 상태로 삼고, T를 이 상태에 가깝게 하도록 선택할 거예요.
이렇게 하면서 T도 최소화하고 싶다는 걸 기억해야 해요. T가 바로 쿼리 횟수거든요.
이 확률을 1에 가깝게 만들고 T를 최소화하려면, 상태 벡터의 각도를 Pi / 2에 가깝게 만드는 게 합리적이에요.
그게 사인의 제곱을 크게 만드는 가장 작은 각도거든요. 즉, 벡터를 회전시키면서 확률을 크게 만들 수 있는 첫 번째 기회예요.
T는 정수여야 하니까 정확히 pi / 2를 맞출 수는 없지만,
대략적으로 생각해서 부등식처럼 풀면, 이상적으로
T를 pi / 4 * Theta 빼기 1/2로 선택하는 게 좋다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
하지만 T는 음이 아닌 정수여야 하니까,
이 이상적인 값에 가장 가까운 정수, 즉 pi를 4 곱하기
Theta로 나눈 값의 floor를 취할 거예요. 참고로 floor는 소수 부분을 버리는 거예요.
다시 말해, 주어진 값 이하의 가장 큰 정수예요. 이 식에 따르면
이상적인 값이 정수 사이의 정확히 중간에 있으면 올림하지만, 그건 이 강의에서는 전혀 중요하지 않아요.
그러니 앞으로는 이 특정 T 선택에 집중할 거예요.
그런데 고려해야 할 중요한 사항이 하나 더 있어요. T의 specification이
해의 개수에 따라 달라진다는 거예요. 각도 Theta가 해의 개수에 의존하거든요.
앞으로 편의를 위해 해의 개수를 s로 표기할게요.
다시 말해, 집합 a one의 크기예요. 아무튼 핵심은 우리가 좋다고 가정하는
T의 식이 Theta에 의존하고, Theta는 집합 A1의 크기인 s에 의존한다는 거예요.
해의 개수를 미리 알면 문제없지만,
집합 A1의 크기가 얼마인지에 달려 있어요. 해의 개수를 미리 알고 있으면 문제없지만,
해의 개수를 미리 모르면 Theta가 뭔지 모르니까 이런 식으로 T를 선택할 수가 없어요.
그러면 다른 방법을 써야 해요. s를 모르는 상황은 잠시 후에 다시 얘기할게요. 일단
해의 개수를 알고 있는 경우부터 시작할게요. 먼저 유일한 해가 단 하나만 있는 unique search부터요.
딱 하나의 고유한 해가 있다고 보장되는 경우예요.
강의 5에서 쿼리 문제의 예시로 unique search 문제를 언급했었어요.
입력은 n비트에서 1비트로 가는 함수 f이고, F를 1로 평가하게 하는 고유한 n비트 문자열이 하나 있어요.
목표는 그 문자열을 출력하는 거예요. 그래서
이건 우리가 얘기해온 비구조적 탐색 문제와 같은데, 해가 정확히 하나라는 약속이 있는 거예요. 사실 이게
Grover가 Grover 알고리즘을 소개한 1996년 원래 논문에서 고려한 유일한 탐색 문제 버전이에요.
Unique search에서 s는 1이고, 따라서 이 중요한 각도 Theta는 1/n의 제곱근의 역사인과 같아요.
n이 크면 이 값은 대략 1/N의 제곱근이에요.
각도가 점점 작아질수록 사인 함수가 점점 더 항등 함수처럼 보이기 때문이에요.
이 근사값을 T 선택에 대입하면, t는 대략 n의 제곱근을 4로 나눈 것의 floor예요.
좋아요, Big O of n의 제곱근 쿼리를 사용할 방향으로 가고 있어요.
물론 아직 알고리즘이 얼마나 잘 작동하는지 정확히 살펴보진 않았어요.
N이 128, 즉 2의 7제곱인 예를 살펴볼게요.
함수 f는 7비트에서 1비트로 가고, 고유한 해가 하나 있다고 가정하는데, 알고리즘이 얼마나 잘 작동하는지 알려면
각도 Theta만 알면 돼요. 계산할 수 있어요.
약 0.0885 라디안으로 5도 조금 넘어요. 그 값을
T 식에 대입하면 8이 나와요. 그래서 128개의 가능성 중에서 고유한 해를 8번의 쿼리로 탐색하는 상황이에요.
grover 연산을 반복할 때 상태가 어떻게 변하는지 그림을 그려볼 수 있어요.
이전처럼 상태 K a0와 K A1이 있고,
이 특수한 경우, 즉 unique search에서 Kat A1은 사실 고유한 해에 해당하는 표준 기저 상태예요.
K a0는 고유한 해를 제외한 모든 문자열에 대한 균등 중첩이에요.
모든 문자열에 대한 균등 중첩은 cosine Theta K a0 더하기 sin Theta K A1로 쓸 수 있어요.
K a0와 K U가 이 경우에 가까운 게 맞아요. 방금 본 것처럼 K a0는
거의 모든 문자열의 균등 중첩이거든요. 딱 하나, 고유한 해만 빠져있어요. G를 다시 적용하면 2 Theta만큼 더 회전해요.
그래서 두 번 반복하면 여기 있어요. 여기 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 그리고 8번이에요.
이제 Kat A1에 꽤 가깝다는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 여기서 멈추고 측정하면 고유한 해를 얻을 가능성이 꽤 높아요.
실제로 이 경우에는 고유한 해를 얻지 못할 확률이 약 0.5%밖에 안 돼요.
반면에 권장 횟수인 8번을 넘어서 grover 연산을 계속 적용하면
해를 얻을 확률이 다시 떨어지고, 시간이 지나면서 상태가 원을 돌면서 진동해요.
그래서 높은 확률로 성공하려면 제때 반복을 멈추는 게 중요해요.
이제 선택한 T가 고유한 해를 찾을 확률에 대해, 더 일반적으로 다른 n 값에 대해 생각해 볼게요.
pn1로 Grover 알고리즘이 고유한 해를 찾는 데 성공할 확률을 나타낼게요.
각 가능한 n 값에 대해서요. 1은 해가 하나라는 뜻이고, 이 표기법을 다른 해의 개수로도 확장할 거예요.
2의 소거 제곱인 작은 값들에 대한 이 확률들을 표로 나타내면, n이 2부터 시작해서
확률이 1/2인데 별로 좋지 않아요. 하지만 n이 4이면 확률이 정확히 1이에요. 실제로 완벽하게 작동하는 거예요.
이 두 경우, 특히 n이 4인 경우가 어떻게 작동하는지 직접 살펴보는 건 정말 좋은 연습이에요.
n이 4인 경우, 4가지 가능성 중에서 하나의 해를 찾는 건데,
쿼리 하나만으로 완벽하게 작동해요. n이 커질수록 약간의 변동이 있어요. 확률이
조금씩 오르내리지만 1에 가까워지는 것처럼 보이는데, 실제로 그래요.
확률이 항상 최소 1 - 1/n이라는 게 해석적으로 증명될 수 있어요. 그러니 좋아요.
알고리즘이 완벽하진 않아요. 해를 반드시 찾는다는 보장은 없지만, 특히 n이 크면 꽤 가능성이 높아요.
그리고 n이 4일 때 일어나는 매우 흥미로운 예외도 있어요.
또, 우리가 선택하는 대로 전체 알고리즘을 측정 포함해서 여러 번 실행할 수 있고, 한 번만 성공해도 해를 얻을 수 있어요.
그러니까 이 확률들이 충분하지 않다면, 그냥 알고리즘을 다시 실행해서 쉽게 확률을 높일 수 있어요.
사실 이 확률들이 모두 1/2이라 해도 여전히 유용한 탐색 알고리즘이 돼요.
이제 해가 여러 개 있을 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼게요.
이전과 비슷한 예시로 시작할게요. 역시 n은 128이지만 이번엔
해의 개수 s가 1이 아니라 4예요. 역시 Theta와 T를 계산해 보면
Theta는 약 0.1777, 즉 10도 조금 넘고 T는
이번엔 4예요. 각도는 이전 예시의 약 두 배이고 T는 절반이에요.
이전처럼 그림을 그릴 수 있어요. 시작점이 여기이고
1번 반복, 2번, 3번, 4번이에요. 이번엔 cat A1에 매우 가까워요.
해를 얻을 확률은 이번엔 99.9%를 넘어요.
그런데 모르고서 해가 하나뿐이라고 생각했다면 T를 8로 잡았을 거예요.
그러면 negative K a0에 거의 다 돌아가서 성공 확률이 매우 낮아져요.
그래서 T 선택이 좋을 수도 나쁠 수도 있다는 걸 보여주는 또 다른 예시예요.
s가 1일 때의 좋은 선택이 s가 4일 때는 매우 나쁜 선택이 되는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
s가 1일 때의 좋은 선택이 s가 4일 때는 매우 나쁜 선택이 되는 거예요. 하지만 s를 미리 알고
우리가 정한 방식으로 T를 선택하면, Grover 알고리즘은 해를 찾을 확률이 최소 1 - x / n이에요.
종종 그보다 훨씬 크기도 해요. 최소 s / N이기도 하지만
그건 사실 훨씬 덜 흥미로워요. 더 흥미로운 건 s / N이 작아질수록 성공 확률의 하한이
점점 1에 가까워진다는 거예요. 이미 여러 번 언급했듯이
T는 grover 연산의 반복 횟수뿐만 아니라 쿼리 횟수도 나타내요. 그러면 이 수가 s와
n에 어떻게 의존할까요?
먼저 x가 0과 1 사이에 있으면 역사인(x)는 항상 x 이상이라는 사실부터 시작할게요.
역사인 함수의 테일러 급수를 알면 쉽게 보일 수 있어요. 다른 방법으로도 이유를 알 수 있는데, 여기서는 그냥 사실로 받아들일게요.
그러면 Theta는 최소 s/n의 제곱근이고,
따라서 T는 최대 pi / 4 곱하기 n/s의 제곱근이에요.
그게 사실 Big O of 루트 n보다 더 좋아요. s가 n에 비해 클수록
쿼리 횟수가 줄어들어요. 어떻게 보면 역수가 Theta를 정의한다는 점에서 이 분수가 등장하는 게 놀랍지 않아요.
결국 이 분석에서 중요한 건 Theta뿐이에요. 방금 봤듯이 Grover 알고리즘은 해의 개수를
미리 알 때 꽤 잘 작동해요. 하지만 해의 개수를 모른다면 어떨까요?
꽤 간단한 접근법이 하나 있어요. 반복 횟수를
그냥 랜덤하게 선택하는 거예요. 구체적으로 T를 1부터 pi / 4 곱하기 루트 n의 floor 사이에서 균등하게 랜덤으로 선택하면
꽤 좋은 방법이에요. 이 범위의 상한은 대략 unique search에서 선택하는 쿼리 수이고, 사실
대부분의 경우에 딱 맞는 숫자예요. 이건 각도 Theta가 가능한 한 가장 작을 때예요.
해가 없는 자명한 경우를 제외하고요. 아이디어는 해의 개수를 알았을 때처럼 상태 벡터를 K A1에 정확히 겨냥하는 대신,
기본적으로 랜덤한 각도만큼 회전하는 거예요. 마치 상태 벡터를 무작위로 돌리는 것처럼요.
해가 딱 하나라면 랜덤 스핀이 상태 벡터를 K A1에 가깝게 밀어줄 수도 있지만,
중간쯤만 갈 수도 있어요. 해가 많다면 랜덤 스핀이 상태 벡터를 원을 여러 번 돌릴 수도 있어요. 그래서 이 방법이
1에 가까운 확률로 해를 찾는다고 기대하기는 어렵지만, 해가 있을 때 해를 찾을 확률은
꽤 좋아요. 항상 최소 40%예요. 사실 그게 명확하지 않지만 사실이에요.
놀랍진 않아요. 정말 랜덤한 각도라면 해를 찾을 확률이 50%이기 때문이에요.
아무튼 40%도 나쁘지 않고, 반복해서 해를 찾을 확률을 높일 수 있다는 걸 기억해요.
매번 T를 독립적으로 선택하면서 과정을 반복하면, 해가 있는데 못 찾을 확률이 반복 횟수에 따라 지수적으로 감소해요.
99% 확률로 해를 찾고 싶다면, 이 간단한 접근법을 10번 실행하면 돼요. 역시 매번 T를 독립적으로 선택해서요.
해를 못 찾으면 당연히 해 없음을 출력해요. 해가 없으면
찾을 수가 없으니 항상 정답인 해 없음을 출력해요. 해가 있으면
못 찾고 잘못 해 없음이라고 할 수도 있지만, 그 확률은 매우 작게 만들 수 있어요.
또한 방금 언급한 것처럼 이 방법은 Big O of 루트 n번의 쿼리 또는 f 평가가 필요해요.
그러니 Grover 알고리즘을 사용하면 해의 개수를 미리 모르더라도 Big O of 루트 n 쿼리로
높은 확률로 탐색 문제를 풀 수 있어요. 더 정교한 방법도 있어요.
해의 개수가 늘어나면서 쿼리 수를 줄일 수 있는 방법인데, 자세히 설명하진 않고
핵심 아이디어만 짚을게요. 먼저 T를 1로 시작해요.
그다음 랜덤한 횟수로 Grover 알고리즘을 실행하는데, 상한이 T예요. 처음
2단계에서는 1번 반복으로 Grover 알고리즘을 실행하고, T는 점점 커져요.
해를 찾으면 출력하고 멈춰요. 해를 못 찾으면 T를 크게 하고
다시 시도해요. T가 너무 커지기 전에 과정을 끝내고
해가 없다고 선언해요. 기본적인 아이디어는 간단한 방법과 같아요. 상태 벡터에 랜덤 스핀을 주는 거지만,
여기서는 T가 작을 때 먼저 약하게 스핀해요. 해가 많을 경우를 대비해서요.
이렇게 하면 너무 세게 돌려서 상태가 원을 빙빙 도는 쿼리를 낭비하지 않아요.
하지만 해를 못 찾으면 다시 시도하는데, 조금 더 세게, 또는 잠재적으로 조금 더 세게 돌려요.
이게 작동하려면 T가 증가하는 속도를 신중하게 선택해야 해요. 한 가지 방법은 T를 5/4 시간 T의 올림으로
대체하는 거예요. T가 지수적으로 늘어나는 거고, 직관적으로는 매번 25% 더 세게 스핀한다고 생각할 수 있어요.
T가 이렇게 지수적으로 증가하는 게 분석상 중요해요. 왜 5/4냐고 물을 수도 있는데,
그냥 작동하는 숫자예요. 실제로 작동하는 값의 범위가 있는데, 예를 들어 2는 작동하지 않아요. T를 매번 두 배로 하면
약한 스핀의 이점을 충분히 살리기엔 증가 속도가 너무 빨라요. 아무튼 이 더 정교한 방법의 핵심은
이전과 같은 쿼리 수의 점근적 상한을 준다는 거예요.
Big O of 루트 n / s인데, 해의 개수를 미리 알 필요가 없어요. 참고로
T가 루트 n에 도달하면 과정을 멈출 수 있어요. 그러니까 해가 없으면 Big O of
루트 n 쿼리 후에 그 결론에 도달해요. 이렇게 Grover 알고리즘에서 반복 횟수를 선택할 수 있어요.
이 강의를 마무리하면서 Grover 알고리즘에 대해 몇 가지 간략한 언급을 할게요. 먼저 쿼리 모델 내에서
Grover 알고리즘은 점근적으로 최적이에요. 이 말은 탐색 문제, 또는 unique search 문제를 푸는 쿼리 알고리즘을 Big O of
루트 n보다 점근적으로 적은 쿼리로 최악의 경우 풀 수는 없다는 거예요. 엄밀하게 증명할 수 있는 사실이에요.
실제로 이 사실의 증명이 여러 개 알려져 있어요. 흥미롭게도 이건
Grover 알고리즘이 발견되기 전부터 알려져 있었어요. Grover 알고리즘은 이미 알려진 쿼리 수의 하한과 일치했어요.
때때로 Grover 알고리즘보다 점근적으로 우월하다고 주장하는 방법이 나오기도 해요.
하지만 항상 실수가 있거나 함수 f에 대한 가정이 있거나
점근적으로 Big O of 루트 n보다 적은 쿼리를 최악의 경우에 쓰는 거예요. 엄밀하게 증명할 수 있는 거고,
실제로 여러 개의 알려진 증명이 있어요. 흥미롭게도 이건
Grover 알고리즘이 발견되기 전부터 알려져 있었어요. Grover 알고리즘은 이미 알려진 쿼리 수 하한과 일치했어요.
가끔 Grover 알고리즘보다 점근적으로 우월하다고 생각하는 방법을 제시하는 사람들이 있어요.
하지만 항상 실수가 있거나 함수 f에 대한 접근 방식에 대한 가정이 있거나,
주장을 틀리게 만드는 다른 문제가 있어요. 쿼리 모델 내에서 제대로 작동하면
비구조적 탐색에서 Grover 알고리즘을 이길 수 없어요. 둘째로 Grover 알고리즘은
꽤 폭넓게 적용 가능해요. Grover 알고리즘이 비구조적 탐색 문제에 제공하는 제곱근 속도 향상은
다양한 상황에서 얻을 수 있어요. 예를 들어 때로는 Grover 알고리즘을
다른 알고리즘 위에 사용해서 그 알고리즘 성능을 넘어선 2차 개선을 얻는 것도 가능해요. Grover 알고리즘은
다른 양자 알고리즘 내에서 서브루틴으로도 꽤 흔하게 쓰여요. 간단한 예로
Grover 알고리즘을 사용해서 강의 5에서 언급한 최솟값 문제에서 고전 알고리즘 대비 2차 이점을 얻을 수 있어요.
마지막으로 Grover 알고리즘에서 사용된 기법, 즉 합성되고 반복되어 양자 상태 벡터를 회전시키는 두 반사는
꽤 중요한 방식으로 일반화될 수 있어요.
한 가지 예가 amplitude amplification이라는 기법인데, Grover 알고리즘을 일반화하는 과정을
다른 양자 알고리즘에 적용해서 고전적으로 가능한 것보다 2차적으로 빠르게 성공 확률을 높일 수 있어요.
그 기법은 양자 알고리즘에서 폭넓게 응용돼요. 그러니까 Grover 알고리즘이 가까운 미래에 혹은 언젠가
실질적인 양자 이점으로 이어질 가능성은 낮을 수 있어요. 하지만 Grover 알고리즘은
의심할 여지 없이 근본적으로 중요하고 폭넓게 적용 가능한 양자 알고리즘이에요. 그리고 많은 용도를 가진 더 일반적인 기법을 대표해요.
이번 강의는 여기까지예요. 그리고 양자 알고리즘에 관한 이 시리즈의 단원도 여기서 끝이에요.
쿼리 모델과 그것을 더 표준적인 계산 모델에 연결하는 방법, 그리고 계산 비용 측정에 관한 몇 가지 기초 개념을 다뤘어요.
그다음 위상 추정, 인수 분해, 그리고 마지막으로 Grover 알고리즘을 다뤘어요. 이미 말했듯이
양자 알고리즘에 대해 배울 게 훨씬 많지만, 이 시리즈에서는 다음 단원에서 다른 주제로 넘어갈 거예요. 특히
양자 상태를 특정 종류의 행렬로 나타내는 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화를 살펴볼 거예요.
밀도 행렬이라고 알려진 것들이에요. 이 공식화는 매우 유용하고,
양자 정보의 일부 측면을 이해하는 데 필수적이에요. 그리고 수학적으로도 꽤 아름다워요.
그러니 단원 3에 함께해 주세요.
그럼 다음에 또 봬요!
안녕히 계세요.